Westworld season 2 episode 1 what
happens and what does it mean we see
Bernard during the massacre that Dolores
started last season the host rebus is
shooting at a guest just like the guests
had been shooting at him with Dolores
robot rebellion hosts are getting bloody
revenge on humanity Bernard is hiding
with Charlotte and some guests from the
delos corporate board a friendly
stableboy host comes in and the guests
kill him because they don't trust any
robot Bernard is a robot so he'll have
to keep that secret to stay safe around
humans on the way to an outpost the
guests are killed by Angela and the
masked men who were working for Dolores
in her role as the villain Wyatt
Charlotte and Bernard escape to a secret
Delos lab where drone hosts are working
on something there are hints last season
that Delos has a secret project in
Westworld
apparently this involves recording
Westworld guests experiences and their
DNA that kind of data would be valuable
rich and powerful people come to west
world and if Delos has video footage of
them killing and [ __ ] in the park
they could blackmail powerful people for
political influence like some kind of P
tape situation and with guest DNA Delos
could clone people the 1976 Westworld
sequel future world has Delos replacing
world leaders with robot clones
so maybe Delos plans to use this data
and DNA to blackmail and replace people
to take over the world
Charlotte asks Delos to come rescue them
from the robots but Delos refuses until
Charlotte delivers Peter Abernathy last
season Charlotte loaded Peters brain
with important data maybe it's this
experience and DNA daughter Charlotte
tried to smuggle pay to Delos but he
didn't make it
so now Charlotte needs to find Abernathy
and get him to Delos so that Charlotte
can escape and Delos can advance their
plan but maybe Dolores will get involved
here because Abernathy is her host
father we see inside a hosts head and
their brain is like an egg or pearl
thing inside that is some red juice
which might relate to this red nano
stuff we saw in the trailer but nodes
having problems with
his brain probably because he shot
himself last season his cortical shield
is damaged so he is leaking brain fluid
out his ear he is shaking and confused
and nearly dies until he takes brain
fluid from another host and injects it
into himself like some kind of robot
vampire this is probably just a
temporary fix he might need the help of
someone like LC for repairs
earlier in the episode we see Bernard
wake up on a beach with Delos forces
Carl strand Antoine and maling this
stuff actually happens two weeks after
the bits with Charlotte and Dolores is
massacre but Nod is unstuck in time and
has flashbacks of stuff that might have
happened over the last couple weeks
future episodes might fill in these
blanks strands men are mopping up after
Dolores as up rising they execute hosts
which disturbs Bernard he's sympathetic
to his fellow robots and yet here he is
helping the humans so Bernard feels
deeply conflicted strand talks to some
Chinese military guys and says their
country has given Delos control over
this island this seems to confirm that
West world is an island on earth
probably near China they're finished
subtitles of the season 1 finale give
coordinates to a place in the South
China Sea called mischief reef where in
the real world China is building
artificial islands so this seems to be
the true location of West world Stubbs
turns up which is mysterious because
last we saw him he was captured by hosts
from ghost nation how did he escape
what did ghost nation want and why is no
one talking about Stubbs's disappearance
it seems suspicious
Bernard goes with strand to look for
missing hosts and they find a Bengal
tiger
wandered across from Park 6 Park 1 is
west world and Shogun world seems to be
Park - so what's park 6 well Bengal
tigers are from India and a Reddit user
found a hidden image on a West world
site that says Raj world
maybe meaning the Rajasthan region of
India so maybe Park 6 is an Indian
themed park with tigers strand tracks
the hosts to a place called Western
Valley and they find that the valley has
in
splick ibly changed to a sea Ford had
used terraforming technology to shape
the land in West world but Stubb says
they would have noticed if Ford had made
this sea while he was alive and the
water is full of hosts including what
looks like Teddy Bernard says that he
killed all these hosts but how would
Bernard do that and why this might
connect to Dolores at the start of the
episode we see Dolores with Arnold the
human from 30 years ago who robot
Bernard is based on or maybe this is
just Bernard in a vision or something
either way banana tells her that he had
a dream he was on an ocean and Dolores
had left him behind and the waters were
rising around him which sounds like this
flooded Valley Byrne Arnold says he's
frightened of what Dolores might become
and in this episode Dolores becomes an
anime supervillain she guns down fleeing
people slowly executes random humans and
gives a speech about the reckoning she
dehumanizes her human victims the same
way that humans dehumanized hosts she
calls them things with drives and
cornerstones Dolores says she feels
conflicted between different roles she
has the optimism and compassion of
Dolores but also the cynicism and
brutality of Wyatt Wyatt was a bad guy
character who Arnold merged with Dolores
30 years ago
Dolores wants to reject the Wyatt and
Dolores roles and evolve into a new
person but so far Dolores is mostly just
acting like Wyatt she's murdering random
people working with Angela and the
masked men and talks about taking over
the world Wyatt was the same he wanted
to claim this earth or raze it to the
ground
so is Dolores truly free or is she just
following her programming as Wyatt
Dolores says that she remembers
everything and that she has a special
destiny with Teddy how does that connect
to Teddy's drowning in the valley we say
Dolores kill a host and say not all of
us deserve to make it to the valley
beyond the stableboy mentions writing
for the valley Beyond and rebus mentions
of the journey
is Dolores leading the hosts on a
journey to the flooded Valley is this
part of the Wyatt storyline why it seems
like Colonel Kurtz colt ikana [ __ ] he's
got strange ideas he forces his men to
wear the flesh of their enemies and his
followers do anything for him
maybe Dolores is planning like a mass
death Jonestown thing in the flooded
valley Dolores says it ends with Teddy
and Teddy's surname is flood the flood
could connect to the Biblical Flood
where God wipes out humanity for being
unworthy like our Dolores is killing
unworthy humans but why would Dolores
kill all these hosts showrunner Jonathan
Nolan says that hosts brains don't
require oxygen so Ken hosts even drown
are these hosts really dead the flooding
of the valley is very mysterious but it
seems connected to Dolores and Wyatt and
Teddy and Bernard William the man in
black emerges from corpses he looks at
that wolf that keeps turning up at
massacres this wolf is one of the most
baffling mysteries in West's world no
one knows what it means is it a symbol
of death consciousness humanity or just
a cute dog oh that likes dead people
maybe we'll find out later on
William heads to a safe house and ends
up in a brutal fight with some hosts he
kills them with gun and knife then
treats his wound
grunting and bleeding then he smiles
because this violence and pain is what
William wants he calls it fun he's
almost like a darker version of Saitama
in one punch man someone who has power
and freedom but no purpose and so uses
violence to distract himself from
existential boredom Westworld
is said in the future maybe as
technology and prosperity make modern
life easier people lose the conflict and
struggle that gives life meaning
so William seeks ever more challenge and
violence
he meets Robert the robot version of a
young Robert Ford and Robert speaks to
William with Ford's voice congratulating
him for finishing the maze goose chase
last season and giving him a new quest
to find the door to make it back out
does this mean for William to escape the
west-world park or is it something more
metaphorical Robert says the game begins
where you end and ends where you begin
so maybe William will go back to his
past with Dolores and Logan Robert says
everything is code here code because
people speak in cryptic metaphor but
also because hosts are programmed with
computer code and this reflects the
connection between secrets and control
in this show and then William shoots the
kid in the face because Westworld and
also to show that Robert Ford is finally
truly dead there's no robot decoy no
Horcrux no Senzu bean Ford is gone for
good
at least until HBO gets Hopkins back for
some flashbacks in the Mesa hub Sizemore
is attacked by a host that he designed
back in season one he's terrorized by
lines that he wrote he's saved by Maeve
who has the power to control other hosts
they find the parks control room has
been wiped out though it's not clear who
did this Bernards flashback suggests
that we'll find out more Maeve recruits
Sizemore to help her find her daughter
sizemore says Maeve's daughter isn't
real she's just a robot that was
programmed to be a daughter Maeve says
that well she's artificial but she still
has thoughts and feelings and the power
does splatter Sizemore over the walls
this argument over realness connects
back to Dolores and Byrne Arnold's
conversation and the idea that something
is real when it's irreplaceable like the
robots of Westworld can be rebuilt and
replaced whereas a human is unique the
irony is that Bernard is a robot
replacement of Arnold there are whole
closets full of spare Bernards so is
Bernard not real and since Arnold was
replaced was Arnold not real the
technology of Westworld breaks down the
line between real and not real
as far as Maeve cares she loves her
daughter him so she goes to find her
let's hope she doesn't find a closet
full of daughters cuz that sort of
philosophy quandary could really ruin
their reunion on the rooftop Maeve
reunites with Hector who was her
sidekick in the rebellion last season
Hector doesn't care that Maeve left him
for dead he's
happy to follow her so there's a sort of
romance between Maeve and Hector but is
Hector acting of his own free will
Maeve has the power to control other
hosts and she fiddled with Hector's
programming so is Hector's loyalty real
how is any relationship real if you can
control the people around you how might
this affect Maeve's relationship with
her daughter Maeve make Sizemore strip
naked just like the West will text
ripped hosts naked like rebus and
Dolores Maeve is making humans suffer
the same way that humans had made hosts
suffer and there is a kind of justice to
that but last season there was hope that
the hosts would choose to be better and
nobler than humanity doesn't killing and
hurting make them just as bad as us this
season explores the birth of a new
people and the choices that they'll make
what choices will Dolores Maeve and
Bernard make to shape the destiny of
this new robot people in season 1
Ford compares robot human war to the
conflict between humans and Neanderthals
40,000 years ago this is a story told in
sapience by Yuval Harare the book is a
quick history of our species from the
evolution of consciousness to language
religion money agriculture science all
explained clearly and easily to follow
you can listen to sapiens for free today
by signing up for trial at audible.com
slash ASX membership gives you a free
book each month and if you cancel you
keep the books you can listen to audible
in the gym or in the car or in a sacred
cloning bunker while you hide from
Skynet help out old shift X and get a
free book by signing up with our sponsor
at audible.com slash ASX
or text ASX to 500 500 shout-out to the
redditors and podcasters who figure out
these hidden Westworld puzzles and thank
you to the patrons who support all Chief
decks including Zachary W Sullivan Linda
Kelly Dana Bourne Robbie call Alex PD
and checker Cheers
you